UNDERCUTS ALL OF OUR
CREDIBILITY, FOR DEMOCRATS WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS KIND OF ISSUE,
YES.
>> JOINING US, A FORMER SENIOR
VISOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MOLLY HEMINGWAY, EDITOR AND
CHIEF OF THE FEDERALIST, AND
VANCOUVER EDITOR OF THE UPCOMING
COMMON SENSE MAGAZINE.
ALL, THANKS FOR JOINING ME.
APPRECIATE IT.
MOLLY, TO YOU FIRST, DO YOU BUY
THE IDEA THAT DEMOCRATS MIGHT BE
WILLING TO THROW OLD JOE BIDEN
UNDER THE BUS HERE?
>> I THINK IT REALLY DOES DEPEND
AT THIS POINT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT WHAT DOCUMENTS ARE THERE.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW BAD THE
SITUATION IS, AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE SEEMS TO BE BEING
PRETTY GENTLE WITH HIM RIGHT
NOW.
THEY HAVE PUT ON A SPECIAL
COUNSEL BUT IT HAS A VERY
LIMITED SCOPE.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY FRIENDLY
WITH HIM ABOUT UNVEILING THIS
DOCUMENT DISPUTE, AND SO IF THE
DEMOCRATS DECIDE THAT IT'S TIME
FOR JOE BIDEN TO GO I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL MAKE LIFE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR HIM.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION YET.
>> SO CHRIS, I LOOK AT WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON DID, RIGHT?
SHE USED BLEACH -- SHE GOT RID
OF HER EMAILS, IT KIND OVER
WORKED FOR HER SO IF YOU HAVE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, F.B.I.
ALLEGEDLY ISN'T LOOKING FOR THEM
AND NATIONAL ARCHIVES DON'T EVEN
KNOW THEY ARE MISSING.
WHY DIDN'T THEY BURN THEM?
WHY DIDN'T THEY SHRED THE
DOCUMENTS BUT INSTEAD THEY GO,
WE HAVE DOCUMENTS AND WE'LL TURN
THEM OVER TO THE DEPTH OF
JUSTICE AND NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
IT SEEMS LIKE SOMEBODY KNEW
THOSE DOCUMENTS WERE THERE?
>> EVERYBODY WAS EXPECTING THE
REPUBLICANS TO MAKE SERIOUS
GAINS AND JOE BIDEN WOULD LOOK
VERY WEAK.
EVERYONE KNOWS JOE BIDEN WAS A
COMPROMISED CANDIDATE, SOMEONE
CHOSEN BECAUSE HE WAS LESS WACKY
THAN HIS COMPETITORS BUT WASN'T
THE FIRST CHOICE OF DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS AND THESE DOCUMENTS WERE
TURNED OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AFTER YEARS AND YEARS OF
SITTING THERE JUST DAYS BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
THE ELECTION DIDN'T GO THE WAY
SOME DEMOCRATS, ACTUALLY MOST
PEOPLE, EXPECTED IT TO GO AND AT
THE END THAT BALL HAD ALREADY
STARTED ROLLING.
THINGS STARTED TO MOVE.
AN INVESTIGATION WAS STARTED AND
NOW IT'S OUT OF HAND.
I'M WONDERING IF THIS WAS
INTERNALLY HIT AGAINST JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
HYPOCRISY AND DOUBLE STANDARDS
THOSE ARE WORDS THAT POWERLESS
PEOPLE USE TO CRITICIZE THOSE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY IN POWER.
DEMOCRATS ARE COMPLETELY IN
POWER.
THEY HAVE DECIDED WHO GETS
PROSECUTED, WHO GOES TO PRISON
AND WHO DOESN'T.
SO WHEN BIDEN GETS IN TROUBLE
WITH THIS BEFORE THE MIDTERM I
START TO WONDER WHO IS
BENEFITING.
>> STEVEN, I SAVED A VERY
SPECIAL MOMENT FROM JEN PSAKI
JUST FOR YOU.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO THIS ARGUMENT THAT THIS
VERY DIFFERENT CASE OF BIDEN'S
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IS GOING TO
BE A POLITICAL PROBLEM FOR HIM
HASN'T EVEN PLAYED OUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE BECAUSE THE
DIFFERENCE, AS YOU SAID, IS WHO
IS DEFENDING DEMOCRACY, AND THE
ANSWER SO THAT IS PRETTY CLEAR.
>> SO IS STEVEN, THEY ARE
TRODDING OUT DEFENDING DEMOCRACY
DEFENSE AGAIN.
IS THAT GOING TO WORK, STEVEN?
>> NO.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
TRYING TO SPIN JOE BIDEN'S THEFT
OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND HIS
FAMILY'S ILLICIT CONNECTIONS
LIKE CHINA, AS A DEFENSE OF
DEMOCRACY IS AN INSULT TO THE
INTELLIGENCE OF EVERY AMERICAN
VOTER AND IF THAT'S THEIR BEST
ARGUMENT YOU'RE IN SERIOUS
TROUBLE.
YOU HAD JAMES COMER ON A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
HE'LL DRILL DOWN AND GET TO THE
VERY ROCK BOTTOM OF IT.
BECAUSE THERE ARE KEY QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE TO BE ASKED.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHY DID THE BIDEN
CENTER, AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, WHERE THERE WAS A
STASH OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
RECEIVE INDIRECTLY ALL OF THESE
FUNDS FROM CHINA?
CHINA GAVE MONEY TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
AND THEN MONEY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA
STARTS FLOWING INTO THE POCKETS
OF JOE BIDEN AND THE BIDEN
CENTER.
WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE?
WHATEVER IT WAS, IT IS SHADY AS
ALL GET OUT.
AND I'M CONVINCED THAT ONCE
ENOUGH SUBPOENAS ARE ISSUED,
ONCE ENOUGH INVESTIGATIONS ARE
LAUNCHED, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND IS GOING TO SHOCK PEOPLE.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
>> MOLLY, ACTIVIST CHUCK TODD
PUT ON HIS I'M A JOURNALIST HAT
FOR A WHILE.
WATCH THIS.
>> SENATOR, DO YOU HAVE A CRIME
THAT YOU THINK HUNTER BIDEN
COMMITTED BECAUSE I'VE YET TO
SEE ANYBODY EXPLAIN, IT'S NOT A
CRIME TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF YOUR
LAST NAME.
>> SO, CHUCK, YOU OUGHT TO READ
THE MARCO POLO REPORT, WHERE
THEY DETAIL ALL KINDS OF
POTENTIAL CRIMES.
>> SENATOR --
>> LET ME STOP YOU THIS.
POTENTIAL --
>> ABOUT --
>> I'LL TAKE IT AT YOUR WORD
THAT YOU'RE ETHICALLY BOTHERED
BY HUNTER BIDEN.
I'M CURIOUS, THOUGH, YOU SEEM TO
HAVE A PATTERN --
>> ARE YOU NOT?
>> I'M A JOURNALIST, I HAVE TO
DEAL IN FACTS.
>> MOLLY, HE'S UNHINGED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> CHUCK TODD IS NOT A
JOURNALIST FIRST OF ALL.
HE SPENT YEARS PUSHING THE
RUSSIAN DERANGEMENT HOAX, THAT
DONALD DUMP HAD WON THE ELECTION
BY COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA TO
STEAL THE ELECTION AND HE WOULD
COME ON DAY AFTER DAY, WEEK
AFTER WEEK, AND BERATE ANYBODY
WHO DIDN'T SHARE HIS CONSPIRACY
THINKING, AND NOW, WHEN WE'RE
ACTUALLY DEALING WITH HUNTER
BIDEN WHO IS UNDER REAL
INVESTIGATION, WHO, WE ALREADY
KNOW HE HAD PROBLEMS PAYING
TAXES.
AGAIN, DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS
VERY FRIENDLY ABOUT LETTING HIM
REPAY SOME OF THE TAXES THAT HE
HAD FAILED TO PAY.
HE'S GOT GUN ISSUES THAT HE'S
DEALT WITH.
DRUG ISSUES, PROSTITUTION
ISSUES.
HE'S BEEN WORKING WITH FOREIGN
OLIGARCHS
AND REGE
WORLD AND THEN CHUCK TODD SAYS I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
HE'S DONE NOTHING BUT RUSH TO
JUDGMENT FOR YEARS.
IT'S ONE OF THESE THINGS, I
THINK REPUBLICANS NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHETHER THEY SHOULD EVEN,
YOU KNOW, BE ON A SHOW WHERE YOU
HAVE SOME SORT OF DERANGED
CONSPIRACY THEORIST LIKE THAT.
HE HAS SHOWN HIMSELF TO BE
OPERATING IN SUCH BAD FAITH FOR
SO LONG, THERE IS REALLY NO NEED
TO TREAT HIM LIKE A LEGITIMATE
PERSON.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
STOP GOING ON THESE LEFT WING
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
MEDIA PERSONALITIES.
THEY ARE ACTIVISTS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BUT TO THAT POINT, IT SEEMS LIKE
THESE MEDIA OUTLETS AND THEIR
PERSONALITIES ARE MORE DEFENSIVE
OF JOE BIDEN THAN EVEN DEMOCRATS
ARE OF JOE BIDEN.
>> REMEMBER, MEDIA RAN PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN FOR HIM.
HE DIDN'T EVEN GO OUT THERE.
THEY HAD WEIRD SCENES WHERE HE
WOULD SIT INSIDE HIS BASEMENT
AND HAVE CARS TURNING THEIR
HEADLIGHTS ON AND OFF BECAUSE
THEY WERE TOO AFRAID.
THEY RAN THAT FOR HIM.
THEY RAN COVER THE WHOLE TIME.
THEY TURNED ON THE NEW YORK
POPE.
THEY WERE IN FAVOR OF
CENSORSHIP.
THEY GOVERNMENT WORKED WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES LIKE
TWITTER TO SUPPRESS THAT STORY.
HERE YOU HAVE TODD SAYING WHY
INVESTIGATE IT, THERE IS NO
CRIME.
THERE IS A GOOD PIECE AT THE
FEDERALIST, YOU INVESTIGATE TO
FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE KNOW THERE IS CORRUPTION, WE
KNOW HE WAS DEALING WITH FOREIGN
POWERS.
WE KNOW HE WAS ON DRUGS.
WE KNOW HE WAS PAYING $50,000 IN
RENT TO HIS DAD WHILE LIVING
THERE, WITH ALL THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN THE GARAGE.
MAYBE IT'S POKING AROUND ON
THAT.
>> IT'S WORTH POKING AROUND A
LITTLE BIT.
SPEAKING OF HACKS, HERE'S JOE
SCARBOROUGH.
>> TRANSPARENCY, I THINK, WORKS
BEST FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IT WORKS BEST FOR BIDEN HIMSELF,
BECAUSE THEY FIND THE DOCUMENTS,
THEY REPORTED THEM IMMEDIATELY.
A DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN
DONALD TRUMP'S.
ANYBODY WHO SAYS IT'S NOT IS A
POLITICAL HACK.
>> SO STEVEN, WE HEARD FROM
PROFESSOR TURLEY IN OUR FIRST
BLOCK THAT THIS EXPLANATION, I
DOESN'T WORK.
IT DOESN'T WASH.
>> WELL, IT DOESN'T WORK ON 45
DIFFERENT LEVELS.
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH IS THAT
JOE BIDEN ENTERED THE WHITE
HOUSE 14 YEARS AGO.
14 YEARS AGO.
HE LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE IN 2017.
NEWLY RELEASED DOCUMENTS WERE
JUST SUDDENLY DISCOVERED.
SOMETHING, SOMEBODY, SOME
ENTITY, SOMEONE WITH AN
INTEREST, DECIDED TO GET THESE
DOCUMENTS OUT INTO THE PUBLIC
LIKE NOW.
WE'LL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT THROUGH
THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS WHO THAT PERSON WAS
AND WHY IT HAPPENED BUT NOW YOU
HAVE BIDEN'S LAWYERS WORKING IN
SECRET TO PRESENT DOCUMENTS IN
THIS HIGHLY CHOREOGRAPHED
FASHION.
THERE IS CLEARLY, CLEARLY A
COVER-UP INVOLVED HERE
PREVENTING US FROM SEEING WHY
THESE DOCUMENTS WERE STOLEN, WHO
HAD ACCESS TO THEM.
WHO BENEFITTED FROM THESE
DOCUMENTS, HOW DOES THIS INVOLVE
THE PAY FOR PLAY SCHEME THE
BIDEN FAMILY WAS INVOLVED IN.
THESE ARE SERIOUS CRIMES THAT
THREATEN NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> I THINK IT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT WHEN THESE TWO
CASES ARE COMPARED, BIDEN AND
TRUMP, DONALD TRUMP HAD THE
ABILITY TO DECLASSIFY HIS
DOCUMENTS.
JOE BIDEN HAD